it's shocking in the book as well that
Josh's character who seems to be kind of
the main guy gets killed off stage as it
were in the book and not even by the bad
guy whom he doesn't even get to meet but
by some nameless schmoes why is that or
why did that appeal to us although it's
kind of shocking and unconventional you
know it's connected to what the story is
about which is as the world is a
horrible unforgiving and capricious
place and it doesn't you know conform to
one's expectations or certainly you know
genre conventions it was interesting to
us in reading the book that following
this one character and sort of investing
in this character and you believe the
movie is about this character and and
the outcome is going to take a
trajectory that you're more or less
familiar with and Cormac he changes that
three quarters the way through and what
he does is he makes you then sort of
think well if it's not what I thought it
was about what is it about and I think
that's what the last third of the story
in the novel sort of tells you and
that's what we were trying to do in the
movie as well